WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THIS
AND GET BACK TO ALL OF THAT AND
PAOLO IF THE DEVELOPMENTS
WARRANT THAT.
>>> AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR STUCK
IDLE AT PORTS, CRUISE SHIPS WILL
SET SAIL ONCE AGAIN.
ROYAL CARIBBEAN WILL WELCOME
BACK PASSENGERS NEXT MONTH AND
VACCINATIONS WILL NOT BE
PRIORITY.
>> Reporter: THE CRUISE INDUSTRY
IS GETTING READY TO SET SAIL
ONCE AGAIN.
BUT A POLITICAL STORM BREWING ON
LAND, ONE BETWEEN FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DE SANTIS AND
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
SERGEANTS IT WILL BE ANYTHING
BUT SMOOTH SAILING.
RIGHT NOW, MOST CRUISELINES ARE
ADVERTISING SUMMER SAILING WITH
VACCINATION REQUIREMENTS BUT
ROYAL CARIBBEAN ABRUPTLY CHANGED
SHIPS.
ONLY SHIPS DEPARTING FROM
SEATTLE OR BAHAMAS WILL PRIOR
PASSENGERS 16 AND OLDER TO BE
VACCINATED.
NO VACCINATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
ITS SAILING FROM TEXAS OR
FLORIDA, FLORIDA WHERE
BUSINESSES CAN BE FINED FOR
REQUIRING CUSTOMERS TO SHOW
PROOF OF VACCINATION.
>> I WAS SURPRISED.
I THINK THEY ARE ON THE BETTER
SIDE OF IT AND I THINK THEY ARE
BETTER OFF STAYING ON TEAM CDC
RATHER THAN TEAM DE SANTIS.
>> THIS LAWYER IN MIAMI SAYS THE
INDUSTRY IS TRYING TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE.
>> THERE APPEARED TO BE A
WAITING PATTERN HERE.
>> Reporter: LAST YEAR A NUMBER
OF CRUISESHIPS WERE UNABLE TO
DOCK WHEN CORONAVIRUS SPREAD
THROUGH TIGHT QUARTERS.
A NO SAIL ORDER WAS SET INTO
PLACE AND SHIPS SET IDLE FOR 15
MONTHS.
NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO GET BACK
TO SAILING.
EITHER WITH TRIAL SAILINGS OR
ABIDE BY REGULATIONS WHERE AT
LEAST 95% OF PASSENGERS AND CREW
ARE VACCINATED.
DE SANTIS HAS SUED THE CDC OVER
THIS.
>> MAKE NO MISTAKE, HAD WE NOT
DONE WHAT WE DID, AND I THINK A
LOT THE CRUISE LEIGHS WOULD
ADMIT THIS, HAD WE NOT DONE WHAT
YOU DID BY SUING YOU WOULD NOT
BE TALKING ABOUT SAILING RIGHT
NOW.
THERE HASN'T BEEN A SINGLE
ELECTED OFFICIAL IN THIS COUNTRY
WHO HAS DONE MORE TO LIBERATE
THE CRUISE LINES FROM A
BUREAUCRACY THAT IS TOTALLY OUT
OF TOUCH.
>> IN MY OPINION, IT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH HELPING A BUSINESS,
NOTHING TO DO WITH KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE.
IT HAS TO HIM PLAYING TO A VERY
SMALL BUT VOCAL BASE OF HIS
SUPPORTERS IN AN EFFORT TO WIN
IN 2024.
>> Reporter: WINKEL SAYS DE
SANTIS LIKELY WON'T WIN THIS
LAWSUIT.
THE HERALD SAYING THE CRUISE
INDUSTRY WANTS TO GO BACK TO
WORK.
THE CDC ISN'T THE ISSUE HERE.
THE BADLY CONCEIVED VACCINE
PASSPORT LAW IS.
THIS TRAVEL AGENT WHO SPECIALIZE
INSIDE CRUISES SAYS MOST PEOPLE
HOPING TO GET ON A CRUISE SOON
ARE ALREADY VACCINATED OR
PLANNING TO BE BEFORE THEY
BOARD.
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE JUST SO
EXCITED THEY DIDN'T GET TO
CRUISE LAST SUMMER OR THIS
WINTER.
THEY ARE WILLING TO, WHATEVER
THE CRUISE LINE NEEDS ME TO DO,
I WILL DO IT BECAUSE I WANT TO
GET ON THAT SHIP.
>> I CHECKED WITH THE FLORIDA
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, THE STATE LAW
DOES ALLOW BUSINESSES TO ASK
CUSTOMERS IF THEY ARE VACCINATED
BUT THE CUSTOMER DOESN'T HAVE TO
ANSWER AND IT CANNOT BE A
CONDITION OF ENTRY.
THE CDC SAYS RIGHT NOW, ANYONE
GETTING ON A CRUISE, EACH IF
THUR FULLY VACCINATED, SHOULD BE
TESTED BEFORE AND AFTER THE
TRIP.
AND THOSE WHO ARE UNVACCINATED
SHOULD QUARANTINE AFTER THE
CRUISE EVEN IF THEY TEST
NEGATIVE.
NATASHA CHEN, CNN, ATLANTA.
>>> JOINING ME NOW, THE POINTS
GUY, BRIAN KELLY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS CRUISE
INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
RAVAGED BY THE COVID OUTBREAK.
YOU SAW WHAT NATASHA WAS TALKING
ABOUT THERE IN HER PIECE ABOUT
GETTING BACK OUT ON THE OPEN
SEAS.
THERE WERE PEOPLE STRUCK ON
CRUISE SHIPS THOUGH FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME BECAUSE OF COVID
OUTBREAKS.
DO YOU SEE PEOPLE GOING ON THESE
CRUISES AND BEING VACCINATED NOT
BEING A REQUIREMENT?
I SUPPOSE SOME PEOPLE WILL GO
FOR IT BUT A LOT OF FOLKS MIGHT
BE WORRIED ABOUT IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE LAST HEADLINES WE KNEW AS
THE PANDEMIC WAS KICKING OFF
WERE THE HORRIBLE STORIES ABOUT
PEOPLE BEING CAUGHT ON SHIPS.
WE KNOW THE VIRUS TRANSMITS ON
CREWS SHIPS EFFECTIVELY.
I WAS SURPRISED TO HEAR ROYAL
CARIBBEAN REVERSE COURSE ON THE
VAC NATIONS.
TIME WILL TELL.
ESPECIALLY PARENTS WITH KIDS WHO
ARE NOT VACCINATED, THEY ARE
GOING TO WANT TO HAVE MOST THE
PEOPLE ON THOSE SHIPS
VACCINATED.
>> UNITED AIRLINES JUST PENNED A
DEAL TO BUY SUPER SONIC JETS.
WE HAVEN'T HAD SUPER SONIC
PLANES FOR SOME TIME NOW.
THEY CAN FLY FROM NEWARK TO LON
DON IN THREE AND A HALF HOURS.
SAN FRANCISCO TO TOKYO IN SIX
HOURS.
THAT'S PRETTY REMARKABLE.
WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
CONCORD.
IS THIS GOING TO WORK, DO YOU
THINK?
>> I THINK IT WILL.
YOU KNOW, BASED ON HOW BOOM
SUPER SONIC IS MAKING THEIR
PLANES.
IT IS GOING TO COST THE AIRLINE
ROUGHLY THE SAME AS MODERN
AIRPLANES DO TODAY, 787.
THEY ARE ALSO GOING TO BE NET
CARBON ZERO, WHICH IS SHOCKING.
THE CONCORD WHICH RETIRED IN
2003 WAS INEFFICIENT TO RUN AND
ALSO IT WAS KINDS OF NOT GOOD
FOR PASSENGERS EITHER.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS A COOL
EXPERIENCE IT WAS HOT IN THE
CABIN AND CRAMPED.
THE BOOM SUPER ON SOIC PLANES
LOOK NICE, BUT IT IS GOING TO BE
2029 BEFORE WE SEE THEM.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE CAN YOU FIT
ON ONE OF THE SUPER SONIC JETS?
IS IT A LOT?
>> IT IS NOT A LOT.
I BELIEVE IT IS ABOUT 50 SEATS.
THEY HAVEN'T ELISED HOW IT IS
GOING TO BE CONFIGURED.
YOU ARE PROBABLY TO THE GOING TO
GET AS MUCH ROOM AS A FULL
BUSINESS SUITE ON A REGULAR
PLANE.
TIME IS MONEY.
AND ESPECIALLY CUTTING THE TIME
IN HALF IT IS GOING TO BE A GAME
CHANGER.
>> AFTER YOU GET OFF OF ONE OF
THOSE SUPER SONIC JETS, IT FEELS
GOOD TO JUMP IN THE POOL.
HAVE YOU SEEN THIS.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
THE SKY POOL IN LONDON THAT
STRADDLES TWO BUILDINGS 115 FEET
IN THE AIR.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS A JOKE ON
TWITTER WHEN I SAW THIS LAST
WEEK.
BUT THIS IS REAL.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THIS?
I HAVE TO ASK, BRIAN, WOULD YOU
TAKE THE PLUNGE?
>> I HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A FEAR
OF HEIGHTS BUT I WOULD TOTALLY
DO IT.
I HAVE BEEN AT THE HOTEL POOLS
AT A RITZ HONG KONG 100 AND SOME
STORIES HIGH.
YOU COULD SAY IT IS THE GOLDEN
AGE OF HOTEL POOLS EVEN THOUGH
THIS POOL IN PARTICULAR IS A
RESIDENTIAL ONE.
TODAY IT IS ALL ABOUT THE
INSTAGRAM SHOT.
WHAT BETTER POOL INSTAGRAM SHOT
THAN THAT ONE.
>> IF I CAME RUNNING AND YELLED
"CANNON BALL" HOW WOULD THAT GO
OVER?
I DON'T THINK WOULD GO OVER
WELL?
>> I THINK YOU WOULD BE FINE.
>> THE GUYS IN THE STUDIO HERE